[Music]
they are the k-pop group taking the
world by storm
BTS made their mark in America this year
in a huge way and it all started at the
Billboard Music Awards that night the
boys beat out names like Justin Bieber
and Selena Gomez for top social artists
[Music]
the group topped the iTunes charts in 73
countries with their new EP love
yourself firm 2 months later they
returned to the US and BTS mania ensued
and I was literally in the middle of the
chaos
the BTS army was in full force at LAX
Airport to catch a glimpse of the guys
who were in town for their
history-making performance at the
American Music Awards we got a special
invite to their rehearsal near the first
Korean boy band to perform on the AMAs I
mean what does that mean you guys was
wonderful you know it was a dream
a week later BTS broke the Guinness
World Record for most Twitter
engagements and became the first k-pop
group to top the US iTunes chart with
the mic drop remix featuring Steve Aoki
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they capped off their visit to the
states with stops at Ellen Jimmy Kimmel
and James Corden 2017 was an amazing
year for BTS and next year they told me
they planned a tour around the world so
gear up army and y'all deserve it I can
safely say army you guys are the best
fans in the world
[Music]
you
[Music]